out here in the Mojave there's testing
Rockets and then there's testing runs to
be a kick-ass rocket company you know
you need to test a lot
the folks who succeed are able to
iterate quickly many of America's top
rocket ears work here
it's the Mojave Airport which is
situated smack dab in the center of
Mojave the town this is where the big
kids play with fire and the pyromaniacs
over at Virgin Galactic hooked Azul
offered tourists a chance to visit space
for about two hundred fifty thousand
dollars per ticket for about twice that
on StubHub George Whitesides is a NASA
veteran and serves as the CEO of Virgin
Galactic he gave me a tour of their
operations which includes a test stand
for braking in rocket engine Nature does
not like what we're trying to do here
the art of this is taking something that
nature doesn't want and sort of bending
it into an outcome virgin spaceship will
be carried into the air underneath the
plane the spaceship will then fire up
its own thrusters and head for the
heavens
it's a complex system and there are a
few places on earth where you can work
out the kinks it's the only place in the
United States where you can design
manufacture and test a rocket motor and
then integrate it on a spaceship and fly
it into space you know this is this is
really the frontier of American
aerospace Virgen wants to offer more
than just a joyride it thinks people
visiting space even for just a few
minutes will have a profound effect on
how we all see our planet you know if
we've got 700 people order magnitude
signed up to go on our spaceship that's
more than the number of people who have
ever been to space in 50 years but
they're going to go back to communities
all over the world and they're gonna
bring that perspective with them I think
that's gonna have a really important
effect the story of virgin has been one
of great promise and devastating
setbacks in 2014 the company's first
spaceship crashed to the ground killing
the copilot and injuring the pilot today
this press event virgin hopes to restore
confidence in its technology by
unveiling spaceship to Richard Branson's
attempt to resurrect the Galactic Empire
from the ashes
this one has taken more than 10 years
you're still not at the point where
we're flying yet how difficult has this
business been compared to your others it
is rocket science it is really difficult
we're just reinventing the wheel
completely reinventing the technology so
it's been tough but we now have rockets
that we know will take us to space you
know we feel confident that we're
finally very very close to being there
ever a good and devoted son Branson
decorated the spaceship with his
mother's likeness and ever the good
showman used the spaceships unveiling as
an excuse to throw a birthday party for
his granddaughter that's a bottle of
milk made out of sugar and used for the
customer in 2014 after the accident how
close were you to terminally I don't
think I've ever given up on anything in
life but we would have been
irresponsible not to ask the questions
the important thing is not to hurry a
program like this you've important
things to get it right and make sure
it's safe for people to go up and and
that we offer return tickets not single
tickets